holy crap everybody we got our first
look at iron man's new armor for
infinity war i also did a montage of all
of his MCU armors so far up through
homecoming there's a new round of the
spider-man giveaway for those IMAX gift
certificates all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber leave a comment on
this video I'll name a new winner at the
end of this but the big stuff we got a
look at the new Iron Man armor this
would be the mark 48 because the 47 is
the homecoming armor and you may have
noticed that it looks very familiar if
you're a big comic book fan they always
take cues from the comics but the MCU
versions are a little bit different and
they're always tailored to what he needs
to do in the movie the fight that he has
the villain he has to face so what I'll
do after this is I'll show the evolution
of his armor and the MCU I'll do a big
montage but right now this looks a lot
like his comic book space armor which
makes sense because it's infinity war
the closest we've ever gotten to space
armor was during Iron Man 3 when we saw
the concept footage for all the crazy
armors that he made when he went
completely nuts this is the star boost
mark 39 it just made for suborbital
flight is not made for him to travel in
deep space so there's been a couple
different versions of the space armor so
you see how this is the natural
evolution of his mark 47 which is just
an evolution of his civil war armor I
don't think he's gone full extremity yet
because you see him walking around on
set with all the nodes on him I think
those are just reference points for the
CG people because when Robert Downey jr.
film scenes as Iron Man
he doesn't wear the armor he walks
around with reference points then they
add the armor in CG later he hasn't
really genuinely worn an Iron Man suit
around on set a lot since Iron Man 2 I
think it was by Iron Man 3 they gotten
to the point where CG was good enough
that they didn't have to put him in the
costume every single time they wanted
Iron Man seems but there's been a lot
that's been made about the arc reactor
that's in his chest here so there's this
picture of the Illuminati just hanging
out chilling drinking Lacroix like it's
no big deal
Mark Ruffalo is like this is not a
Lacroix ad I promise you we're just
hanging out on set having our lunch
Bendis went nuts when he saw this
because he's the guy that actually wrote
that moustache Bros lines everybody
quotes all the time please let them
high-five in the movie at some point but
all
the actors have rapped and people saw
this mark in Tony Stark's chest and
they're like wait a minute didn't he get
rid of that an Iron Man 3 he doesn't
have an arc reactor in his chest anymore
does something happen does the time gem
turn him back and make it put him back
in his chest no I think what it is is
it's just a reference point for the CG
later when he's wearing the full suit
when they're filming scenes they have
Robert Downey jr. but then they also
bring this on set so he walks around
with a portion of the suit on sometimes
sometimes they'll put it on a dummy but
the first time he ever works based armor
was Iron Man number 142 back in 1981 he
got an upgrade to that in 1992 in Iron
Man 278 you can see the infinity war
shoulders look a lot more like this so
it's a little more contemporary there
was a satellite armor during 2008 during
the Skrulls invasion that's exactly what
it sounds like it's a satellite that
turns into an Iron Man suit it's like a
space version of the Hulk Buster there
was the third version of the space armor
in 2012 an Iron Man number 527 the
really cool space armor he wore when he
was with the guardians of the galaxy is
just a fourth version of that that was
from 2013 in Iron Man vol 5 number 5 and
then the more recent version of the
armor is model 51 that's the one that's
modular it'll just turn into whatever
armor he needs it to be it condenses
down to a wristband like he can
literally walk around with his watch on
and it has forms around him and he can
turn it into a Hulk Buster when he needs
to so it can become really big it can
become small it can fix itself if it
gets destroyed so if a bunch of pieces
get blown off of them
it can auto repair itself so it's almost
like a second skin but it's not
extremity
so as for new functions that we might
see Iron Man suit have an infinity war
I'm guessing maybe stealth mode maybe a
little more modular like an upgrade from
his Civil War watch which was just a
hand piece maybe he's perfected that so
that he could just walk around with the
suit on even though it doesn't look like
he's wearing it where you see Tony Stark
walking around in his parka here but the
armor is still on it's just that you're
seeing right through it
so let me know what do you guys think
about this design it definitely looks
more stylized which i think is really
cool but here's the montage of all his
MCU armors so far my turn
thanks Perry to power down and begin
diagnosed ah yeah tell you what doing
whether an ATC checks start listening in
on ground control ready and three two
[Music]
you
[Applause]
what do you want to be where you going
we talking about I'm having the gun you
are not the big gun Tony
don't be jealous no subtle all the bells
and whistles yes it's called being a
badass fun yeah
[Music]
sit down
those yeah
[Music]
Merry Christmas bunny
Jarvis target extremis heat signatures
disabled with extreme prejudice
[Music]
you're waiting for Christmas
it can be cured one let's go to you
[Music]
I'm the best
you're gonna break your old man's heart
alright everybody stand down
Romanoff you and banner better not be
playing hide the zucchini
[Music]
Wow it's so weird how you run into
people at the airport thank you guys
we're definitely weird
what if somebody dies tonight different
story right because that's on you I
wanted you to be better so let me know
in the comments what's your favorite
Iron Man armor so far it could be from
the comics or from the MCU his god
killer armor is something we might see
some point in the comics and yes I do
think that he'll get another version of
the armor when we get to the fourth
Avengers film every movie he gets an
upgrade even if they don't hype it up
but what's going to happen next is
they'll be some new spider-man Home
Coming Marvel phase 4 Kevin Feige
explained a whole bunch of stuff about
what's coming after the fourth Avengers
film and it was a really cool Easter egg
that they've revealed way back from Iron
Man 2 so videos for that coming really
soon congratulations to the latest
spider-man giveaway winner Spartan
ghosts pls private message me so I can
get your contact details while you wait
for everything click here for my
non-spoilery spider-man homecoming
review and you can click here for the
brand-new Inhumans teaser trailer thank
you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you